Speaker 1: This is an unbelievable story. The
Texas attorney general, Ken Paxton, fled his
home in a truck to avoid being handed a subpoena.
Imagine the imagery of this. CNBC has a good and
simple and straightforward write up of this. Texas
AG Ken Paxton fled home with his wife to avoid a
subpoena in an abortion case. According to a court
filing released earlier this week. Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton allegedly fled his home
with his wife to avoid being served a subpoena,
according to a sworn affidavit. The subpoena
ordered the Republican attorney general to appear
and testify in a civil lawsuit in which multiple
Texas based nonprofits want to resume helping
pregnant residents obtain abortions in other
states. A federal judge quashed the subpoena.
Paxton on Twitter claimed he was showing concern
for his family and later said that the process
server, the process servers, the individual who
delivers the subpoena is lucky. This situation did
not escalate further. That's a quote. PAX. Look
at these details. Paxton ran from the garage or
garage. As some say, Paxton ran from the garage of
his home in McKinney, Texas, into a truck driven
by his wife, State Senator Angela Paxton, while
refusing to accept the documents from a process
server. According to the affidavit filed in
court, the Paxton's drove away without taking
the documents which were left on the ground by the
house. According to the process server. Federal
Judge Robert Pittman granted a motion Tuesday to
quash the subpoena. Paxton argued the subpoena
was unwarranted because none of the requisites
for making or enforcing such a demand have been
satisfied. In a statement Tuesday, Paxton accused
the server of posing a threat by charging at him
and yelling unintelligible. Oh my goodness.
This is the guy who was indicted for felony
securities fraud charges years ago, hasn't face
consequences, hasn't been put on trial. He still
won his Republican primary. And remember, as long
as it's not a Democrat, Republican voters don't
care what these people do. They claim to be for
law and order. Part of law and order is listen.
A legally created and obtained subpoena delivered
by a process server, a legitimate process server.
And you just run away and jump into a truck and
drive away. That's not law and order. And again,
the law and order crowd adhering to the principle
of, well, law and order for everybody else. This
is a characteristic of authoritarianism. There
is no rules for the insiders and the cronies.
And as I read this story and as I think about
the perspective of these individuals on what
law and order means to them, and I don't mean to
them for society. I mean to them when they are
the ones involved with the judicial system.
It really is reminiscent of Putin's Russia.
And yet there is a cartoonish nature for sure
here of Paxton running away and jumping. You know,
it's Texas. He probably had a belt buckle that
was huge. And he runs and jumps into a pickup
truck. I get it. The imagery is cartoonish. The
imagery is funny to some degree. But the real
story here is the authoritarian nature of law
and order for everybody else. And in fact, using
the justice system and law enforcement to their
advantage as tools when it's for other people,
and then when it comes to them, they just say, no,
it was illegitimate, or I'm going to jump into a
truck and run away. It's really the same thing
with the Trump search warrant at Mar a Lago,
which is, hey, you know what? We back the
blue, the thin blue line. Support the police,
except when it's the Capitol Police at
the Trump riots. Well, in that case,
it was the protesters by which, you know, they
mean riders who are actually the heroes. And, oh,
no support law enforcement are great. All these
great people, they get a legal search warrant
signed off on by the attorney general, by the FBI
director, by a judge. They go to Trump's house
and they get the stuff that they're entitled to
get. Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Now, it's not about
support law enforcement. Now it's law enforcement
has been weaponized by Biden, even though Biden
had nothing to do with that search warrant. That's
the theme. And it's an authoritarian theme that we
should all be very careful about and very scared
of legitimately. It's not a slippery slope thing.
It's we should be scared now because of how they
are willing to abandon every single one of these
principles as soon as it's inconvenient to them,
as soon as it comes down on them. So Ken Paxton
jumping into a truck and running away beyond
parody, but therefore, law and order. Don't don't
forget that, guys. They're for law and Order. Let
me know your thoughts. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. We are going to take a very
quick break and be right back. The David Pakman
Show is an audience supported program. We are an
independent media program. We don't have some big
corporate entity that funds us and staffs us up
with dozens of producers doing almost nothing.
I've seen it firsthand, folks know. We have a
small team. Everybody has multiple roles and
many responsibilities, and we're primarily funded
by our viewers and our podcast listeners and our
radio audience. I would love for you to add your
name to our list of supporters by signing up at
join Packman dot com. It's quick, it's easy, it's
painless. It comes with great perks, including
an extra show every single day. Commercial free
audio and video streams of the show just for you,
as well as members only town halls where we invite
our website members to call in and talk to me.
Ask me your questions, tell me your stories,
etc.. Sign up at join Packman dot com and you
can use the coupon code. Obama Now.
Speaker 2: Obama now.
Speaker 1: That's ob a m and a to get a serious
discount off of the cost of your membership.